[Musique]
solidarité la vérité solidarité
démocratie encrassé me prat et vous
sachiez fraternité parité tarifaire
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir puisque je ne sais pas
quelle heure me regarder toute façon
chez nous très tard ou traitant on va
avoir un bon quart d'heure pour cette
nouvelle émission de la campagne
officielle on a choisi autour de
dominique voynet de rassembler un
certain nombre de gens qui vont parler
de thèmes divers et qui surtout
représente un petit peu la variété des
soutiens à la candidature de dominique
alors je vous les présente rapidement
gilbert vasseur wasserman qui est là
comme porte parole de la convention
alternative progressiste marie christine
blandin que vous connaissez sûrement qui
est la présidente depuis 92 maintenant
de la région nord pas de calais dont de
grosses responsabilités
roger winterhalter qui est le porte
parle de l'alternative rouge et verte
merde
x qui s'appelle lutterbach monsieur
pietrasanta yves pietrasanta qui lui est
maire aussi d'une vie s'appelle mèze et
qui est conseiller régional dans le
languedoc ça vous montre un peu la
diversité de ses soutiens et aussi les
responsabilités qu'on les gens autour de
dominique qui ne sont pas simplement des
militants de terrain mais qui sont aussi
engagés des postes institutionnels nous
avons aussi dominique fra ger qui lui
est maire-adjoint plus spécialement
chargé de la santé a colombes est aussi
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france et
marie anne isler béganne vous connaissez
aussi et qui est l'ancienne vice
présidente du parlement européen et
porte parole des verts
voilà alors chacun de vous va nous dire
en quelques mots un petit peu de parler
un petit peu son action sur le terrain
nous dire aussi pourquoi il l'a choisi
de soutenir dominique voynet et on va
commencer par la plus gradée les tiens
marie christine blandin comment ça se
passe dans le nord pas de calais qu'elle
qu'est ce que ça apporte à une région
grandes régions comme le nord pas de
calais une présidence différente de
celle des partis traditionnels les
différences et le scrutin proportionnel
qui a permis l'arrivée d'une écologiste
disons le minoritaire et qui fait que
chez nous il n'ya pas une majorité de
51% qui opprime et qui coupe les parents
les moyens de la minorité de 49%
comme ça se passe dans beaucoup
d'assemblées chez nous le débat est roi
et il ya plus d'intelligence dans la
tête de 113 élus qui discutent qui
confrontent leurs idées que dans la tête
d'une majorité qui confie ce que le
pouvoir n'ont pas droit c'est pas trop
le
le bordel comme vu effectivement on est
obligé de composer on est obligé de
partager on est obligé de d'amender les
projets et comment avec un débat aussi
large peut-on conserver l'écologie parce
que le danger serait de prendre le plus
petit commun dénominateur et ben en
instaurant la démocratie participative
en informant les quatre millions
d'habitants de nos projets du réel de
nos impossibilité de nos possibilités en
les associant au choix en amont en
corrigeant selon ce qui nous renvoie je
prenais seul exemple la coopération
décentralisée région la plus pauvre de
france le plus grand nombre de chômeurs
région la plus jeune est ce bien
raisonnable d'aller mettre de l'argent
régionales vers le tiers monde et va
quand les gens savent que le but que
nous poursuivons un pour cent de
l'argent ça représente 40 fois plus
proportionnellement que les autres
régions mais un kilomètre d'autoroute
il serait prêt à mettre 10 fois plus et
associer les gens la décision c'est la
garantie de la démocratie c'est la
garantie la compréhension
la démarche de dominique qui convoie
donc cette campagne des présidentielles
qui essaye de faire passer notre message
je pense qu'elle est fondamentale elles
montrent qu a pas de solutions toutes
faites les gens cherchent l'honnêteté la
volonté et ils veulent discuter des
solutions techniques vous n'avez pas de
trop de problèmes mandé vote
votre assemblée vous arrivez à vous en
sortir a voté le budget il ya des
régions on n'arrive pas des régions dont
les grands prêtres sont les tenants de
la majorité absolue bas ils n'arrivent
pas à voter leur budget en arrive aux
délais de rigueur ils n'ont pas de
budget ils n'ont pas réussi à dégager
une majorité
alors qu'avec notre proportionnelle
notre système d'animation notre recours
à la population eh ben ça marche
les autres conseillers régionaux l'avons
confirmé cette vision des choses il va
sable et l'arrivée des écologistes et
négocieraient jeunes ont apporté un
séminaire à la politique dépoussiérer la
façon de faire la politique
traditionnelle
et il faut voir le bilan des conseils
régionaux qui sont vraiment attachés à
leur région et qui est très important à
une adhésion
c'est quelque chose de très innovant je
crois alors un maire maintenant mr
alternatif qu'est-ce que tu es ce que sa
special guest que ça c'est spécial sur
le terrain commence à agir sabine fassi
a quelque chose de spécial bon je suis
pas fou j'étais né pendant la panne à la
deuxième guerre mondiale je crois que ça
m'a beaucoup marqué parce que notre
village a été sinistrée presque 100%
et puis ensuite j'ai l'habitude de dire
que je suis un militant né de la guerre
d'algérie on a pris ce qu'on appelle le
pouvoir municipal en 77 et puis depuis
ça dure
77 77 j'étais à l'époque j'appartenais
encore au psu dont je reste attaché à
ses à ses idées assez à cet idéal
et puis on s'est dit ah ben avec nos
moyens avec nos possibilités de limites
on va essayer de mettre en pratique un
certain nombre de choses
expérimenté sur le terrain parce que je
crois que les municipalités sont un très
bon terrain d'expérimentation on est
aussi la première ville à s'être
déclarés zones dénucléarisées à la fois
pour un symbole mais aussi par
solidarité avec ces genres de tchernobyl
et depuis les enfants viennent d
des scientifiques viennent également
discuter avec nous sur les énergies
renouvelables
là on a eu un échec on a voulu avoir un
projet de géothermie
et puis qui ne s'est pas réalisé parce
qu'en france je crois gauche trois temps
un seul combat pour le tuning tout
nucléaire il faut bien le dire
et puis mon nous on pense à autre chose
je crois qu'il faut aussi faire le bilan
de ces échecs mais parallèlement on a on
l'a aussi lié à ce que j'appelle hier je
disais il faut se donner la main
aujourd'hui on dit les solidarités
solidarité avec les plus démunis ont
fait toute une série de projets pour
l'insertion sociale par l'économique
on a lancé l'arn à une association
intermédiaire qui est né n'est rien
d'autre qu'un bureau de placement à but
non lucratif ont fait des chantiers
professionnels pour des contrats emploi
solidarité on a des entreprises
d'insertion notamment la brasserie parce
que c'est un leader basri comme
l'alsacienne vie cligne de l'oeil et
puis là on a elle est fermée depuis 69
et on a relancé une brasserie artisanale
ou qui embauchent à la fois des gens
qualifiés et des gens non qualifiés mais
je crois que là aussi on a compris aux
limites et ça ne suffit pas je crois que
actuellement dans la situation du
chômage crois qu'il faut aller au delà
je pense qu'on parlera de la réduction
du temps de travail en 2003 gère les
problèmes de santé vous c'est votre
domaine qui t'a fait rappelons le quand
même mettre sa comment vous comment vous
gérez ça dans une grande villa dans une
grande ville donc comme que l'omb qui
est une grande ville de l'agglomération
parisienne
évidemment le premier problème c'est je
dirais avec la crise et le chômage on
est si tu es à moi j'habite une cité
populaire de 2000 personnes et je vois
depuis depuis 20 ans je vois bien la
dégradation et les problèmes y compris
de santé au sens large du terme que nous
que nous rencontrons aussi bien pour les
personnes âgées que pour les plus jeunes
c'est d'abord l'accès aux soins
tout bêtement c'est une question qu'on
pensait régler les problèmes comme ça
qu'on croyait régler les acquis qui ne
le sont pas
l'accès aux soins pour tous y compris
c'est la solidarité comme disait roger
pour les plus démunis qui parfois
bon sont toxicomanes par exemple avec un
incident à qui galope dans mon
département qui étaient les plus riches
de france dit on 1 les hauts-de-seine
il ya entre décembre 92 et décembre 93
caisse en cas de sida 31 %
d'augmentation comme taux de progression
et une singularité terrible un mode de
contamination les changes seringues
souillées chez les toxicomanes alors
voilà pourquoi par exemple quand il ya
urgence
je dirais priorité pour limiter la casse
il faut avoir des actions très concrètes
sur le terrain je perds wassermann le
social dans cette campagne
vous êtes un petit peu le représentant
de 2,7 de cette mouvance qui qui a
rejoint petit à petit ou du moins une
convergence entre entre vos sensibilités
et où vous retrouvez donc aujourd'hui à
soutenir dominique comment vous avez
vécu cette campagne quels sont les
thèmes que vous voulez porter en
priorité serait pas seule fois lors
représentants du social normes une offre
elle assume aussi l'écologie je veux
dire par là que pour ce qui nous
concerne nous qui définissons comme la
gauche alternative
c'est vrai que nous pour beaucoup
d'entre nous nous venons de la gauche
traditionnelle justement nous avons tiré
le bilan de ces échecs de ces impasses
et nous essayons de construire un
nouveau projet et pour construire un
nouveau projet mais il nous semble
indispensable de rencontrer l'écologie
et c'est pour ça que nous nous plaidons
pour un véritable mariage du socialisme
et de l'écologie au fond les logiques du
productivisme exacerbée et les logiques
de l'argent roi de la recherche du
profit maximum
c'est quand même fou les mêmes logiques
c'est une idée qui vend sur c'était le
titre d'un grand quotidien du soir hier
si mais je te vends une nous nous sommes
très contents que dominique venait ait
pu tout au long de cette campagne
commencé à avancer ses idées là et je
crois que c'est les idées de l'avenir
c'est les idées du rassemblement que
nous avons à faire mais alors est-ce que
le maïs faire vegas que justement a
contrario on peut pas dire que cette
campagne a un peu passer sous la table
les vrais problèmes écologiques qu'est
ce qu'on pense là pour parler
non mais reproche qu'on m'entende
pourtant pas du tout parce que la preuve
est faite que aujourd'hui nombre de
partenaires ont intégré aujourd'hui
l'écologie
pour nous l'écologie c'est un tout le
social est intégré dans l'écologie
l'environnement est intégré dans
l'écologie donc je crois qu'il ya encore
quelques pas en avant à faire mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut le rappeler quand même
l'environnement c'était le premier
combat des écologistes il ya 20 ans rené
dumont monsieur mono jean pierre raffin
ce sont les personnes qui portent qui
ont porté ces les couleurs de l'écologie
depuis 20 ans aujourd'hui elle se
concrétise par des élus dans les
différentes institutions
moi même j'étais pendant cinq ans au
parlement européen où nous avons
réellement travailler nous avons essayé
de montrer que aussi bien en france en
europe dans les pays de l'est que dans
les pays du sud aujourd'hui nous devons
passer un développement écologiquement
soutenable
ce que nous ce que nous appelons ici la
transformation écologique de la société
donc et c'est vrai que en regardant ce
qui est fait en france en acquérant
environnement qu particulièrement on
n'avance pas riou c'était il ya trois
ans berlin c'était yahia et c'était hier
rien n'avance pour me donner juste un
chiffre le chiffre du budget du
ministère de l'environnement 1,7
milliard ce qui équivaut au
fonctionnement de la très grande
bibliothèque nationale donc si
aujourd'hui le choix politique qui est
fait en france c'est pas le choix de la
santé c'est pas le chouette
environnement c'est pas le choix de
l'écologie c'est pas le choix du social
on ne voit pas envie d'investir ni dans
l'eau ni dans l'air alors que voir
bouger
trouvez la prendre il faut vraiment être
des écologistes de terrain c'est sur le
terrain qu'on peut faire le
développement local est relié avec
développement durable dont elle parle et
on peut parler des grands problèmes
dominique a parlé dans la campagne toile
mais deux des problèmes des déchets de
leur recyclage
la propreté de l'eau la pureté de l'air
c'est très important ce qui se passe
dans nos campagnes de nos villes dans
nos villages c'est très important tout
ça est donc avec le parti écologique
notamment créé que nous représentons
avec dominique le frère nous nous sommes
dit manistes nous avons pensé que
dominique voynet
c'est vraiment elle s'y représenter
l'écologie terrain et c'était c'est elle
qui nous présente dans cette campagne
des produits de chasse ont écouté tout
ça sans oublier comme le rappelait marc
était sous mandat
les problèmes de développement les
problèmes nord-sud et c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment je suis au coeur de notre
démarche commune dominique il
t'appartient au plur oui j'ai eu
l'occasion tout au long de cette
campagne de défendre avec beaucoup
d'énergie et de conviction un projet
politique pour entrer dans le 21e siècle
un projet qui donne tout son sens à ce
terme de développement soutenable que
nous avons mis en avant un projet qui
insiste sur la nécessité de partager
mieux les richesses de diminuer le temps
de travail de pensée des transports
collectifs accessibles et confortable
d'abolir la dette des pays du tiers
monde et de mettre en place des circuits
qui privilégie la coopération
décentralisée et les relations directes
entre les gens j'ai eu l'occasion
d'assister sur les dégâts considérables
d'un modèle de développement qui n'était
maîtrisé par personne et qui était en
fête qui s'était emballé sous la
pression des grands lobbys et deux des
grands corps qui sont assez responsables
face aux lois du marché
mais je tenais dans cette phase
terminale de campagne à être entouré ici
les gens qui l'ont fait avec moi cette
campagne et qui font vivre l'écologie
est l'alternative tous les jours sur le
terrain les gens qui sont des élus qui
prennent des responsabilités qui
expérimentent innove qui créent et qui
qui font le lien en permanence entre
l'action au niveau local et la réflexion
pour un nouveau
cette société qui marie l'écologie le
socialisme la démocratie et qui nous
permettent finalement à nous qui n'avons
pas encore une très longue expérience de
travail en commun de dessiner ce qui
pourrait être un grand mouvement pour
rentrer dans le xxème siècle en portant
l'espoir des gens osent et dominique
voynet
ça change tout
[Musique]